(funky music)
- I would date someone with
a 20 year age difference?
Strongly agree, strongly disagree?
Answer in the comments below
and suggest a prompt on our Kickstarter.
- We've never been married yet.
We want to get married
- Is it like a five year plan.
- Yeah, get it done right now.
(group laughing)
(funky music)
- [Announcer] If you had to rank yourself
against others based on a specific trait,
what would it say about how you see them
and how they see you?
To find out, we brought
together five couples
to rank each other based
on their assumed age gap.
Then we rearrange them based
on their actual age gap.
This is "Ranking".
(timer beeping)
- Say how long we've been together, right?
- Oh yeah.
- Should we go down the line?
- Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
- We're about to hit a year.
- Two days.
- Us too!
- Wait, really?
- The tenth?
- Yes.
(group laughing)
- A year or longer?
- Two years.
- We've been together for four months.
- Yeah.
- We got together,
I think it was in March.
Yeah. March of this year.
No, this last year, this last year.
- Almost a year.
- So, almost a year.
We're almost here together.
- So, we met on Tinder.
We have been together for six months.
- Six, seven months, ish.
- Wanna talk about work?
- I'm unemployed.
I'm going to nursing school.
- [Man] Yes.
- Oh. Okay.
- Walking in and seeing
all of the couples here,
like I felt like I was
for sure the oldest person
- I work at a ninja warrior gym.
She came interested in learning
like how to do obstacles.
Our energies really matched each other.
- That's so cute.
- We're musicians
- Cool
- Together?
- I love that.
- Together and separate.
- So I'm a dog groomer
- And I am going to school right now.
- I graduated school last year.
I've got my real estate license.
My personal training
certificate, figuring it all out.
- What were you guys doing
when COVID broke out?
- I was in school, still in college.
I graduated during the pandemic.
(crickets chirping)
What?
(group laughing)
Did I expose something?
- But anyone can be in college, right?
Like, my mom is in college.
- That's what I'm saying.
I'm like, I was in school.
- Who lives with their parents,
Or do you live on your own?
- [Group] That's a good question.
- I have my own apartment,
but she's always there, so.
- I'm always there.
So I live with my parents,
but if I were to move in with her,
I would have to pay rent
and I don't pay rent with my parents.
- So you got a good move right there.
- We live together.
- We also live together
at my grandparents' house.
- At her grandparents.
- I live with my grandma and my mom.
- I with a roommate.
- Yeah. And, but I'm also always with him.
- [Announcer] So raise your hand,
if you think Zack is older.
- Zack, are you older?
- I am.
- [Man] You are really?
- I think, Zack and Mckayla felt
like they kind of look like
they go to school together.
They kind of look around the same age too.
- [Announcer] Raise your hand,
if you think Mia is older.
- Oh, she's older.
- I'm older.
- It was so hard,
'cause she rolled in with head to toe
like beanie and accessories and tattoos,
which eliminates, like,
I was looking for like some skin aging.
- Thank you, by the way. You were.
- Wait. Who raised their hand?
- I was the only one.
- Oh, okay.
(group laughing)
- Your face were like.
- [Announcer] If you think John is older,
raise your hand.
- This ones so hard.
- I'll say older.
- Yeah.
- I am older.
- They were kind of the same size,
so I was just like comparing that as well.
Like they seem pretty similar,
like their experiences
and how they communicate with each other.
- If you think I'm older, raise your hand.
I'm not older.
(group laughing)
- Well, I mean, if you think
I'm older, raise your hand.
(group laughing)
- No way.
- No, no, no.
I'm kidding.
- Have you been married before,
or are we thinking?
- Oh, have you been married before?
- I have not been married.
I do want to get married.
- Same.
- We've never been married.
Yeah. We want to get married.
- Like is it like five year plan.
- Yeah.
- Like ASAP, but you know.
- Okay. Get it done right now.
- I set it all up.
- Haven't thought about marriage seriously
till I met Matrix.
- Why couldn't you say that too?
You're saying all the right things.
- I feel like this is
such a loaded question.
Yes. I wanna get married.
- I want to get married as well.
- I haven't been married.
He hasn't either.
- It's not a concept that I'm opposed to.
(inquisitive music)
(timer beeping)
- I feel like Matrix and John,
just me and I'm always wrong.
So opposite.
I feel like you might be on
the lower end of the spectrum.
- Yeah. Only one though.
Only one spot.
- By one.
- I feel like you guys have a big age gap.
- That's kind of rude.
- You know what I'm saying?
- I'm just kidding.
(group laughing)
- Everybody looks great.
- I was thinking that too.
I was like us too.
Like top two.
- So I think Matrix
and John move down one.
Where do you think,
where do you move them?
- Swap right here.
- I also have another question.
So like when you're with
your friends or family
like what do they think
about your relationship?
- Yeah. That's a good one.
- First, I actually lied about his age
and then I lied again.
And then I told like my mom,
his actual age and I was like, oh, okay.
Like I knew it.
- So they should stay there.
- Yeah.
- And how about you guys?
- My friends and family were like, why?
- Oh, Rude.
- Rude.
- So my friends, when
they found out at first
they were like same thing as her.
Why? Like they were shocked.
- They did? Say why?
- Y'all there's a lot of drama.
- But my mom, she supports me.
- Like my friend,
she was kind of like,
kind of worried at first.
I was like, just meet him
and then you'll see our relationship.
And then you'll understand.
- Same.
- Yeah.
- I think y'all two should switch.
- Thank you.
- Yeah. Switch like.
- You're so tall.
- I think the three pairs down there,
they're like good.
- I feel like you guys should switch.
I don't know.
- Right.
- Me too.
- He has a baby face.
(group laughing)
- I wanna see your guys
like you guys, like.
- I like twins.
- Oh that's just weird.
- That's yeah, that is weird.
- Do you guys want to switch?
- I think they have you like
- What if we do rock papers, scissors?
I mean.
- I like this so far.
- You like it?
- So far, everyone else is
saying we should switch,
but I like this.
- But you said you're always wrong.
- That's true.
- That is true.
- But maybe we should
believe in you this time.
- Give me one, give me one.
I want this.
(timer beeping)
- I think let's just keep it.
- Let's just keep it.
- It feels nice.
(beeping)
(funky music)
- [Announcer] So, with
the smallest age gap,
we have one year with Zack and Mckayla.
(group claps)
For the next age gap,
we have a tie between two couples,
I have 6 years for both
Braelyn and Hunter,
and Matrix and John.
(group cheers)
- Yes.
- What month were you born?
- July.
- Come on.
- Wait, what about you?
- October.
- October, July.
- October, November, December.
(sci-fi beeping)
So is that two months?
And then how do we do this now?
- Let's switch.
- Yeah. So I feel like
it's technically here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Announcer] On the second spot.
- I'm glad we stayed.
- We have JP and angel.
- I told you.
- We were telling.
- Wait, what was the cap?
- 12 years and 10 months.
- Okay.
- Oh really?
(group talking)
- [Announcer] In spot number one,
we have Mia and Rose with 16 years.
(beeping)
- Wait, so how old are you guys?
- I'm 20.
How old do you think she is?
Oh wait. It's 16 years.
- Exactly.
- So 36.
- Whoa. You don't look 36 years old.
- She's Asian.
- It's the Asian genes.
- He has the Mexican jeans.
- I thought she was younger too guys.
- And I thought she was older,
but them like I thought
you guys were bigger.
- Yeah. That's what I was going say.
- Yours were like, why?
Hers was like why?
- Yeah. Not to get into it too much,
but I feel like it's
also a religious thing.
- Oh yeah, for sure.
- Because like I know that our families
are heavily religious so they're like,
oh, you guys need to be a certain way.
- If you're happy, it doesn't matter.
- No
- For sure.
- Sometimes I forget, he's like 31
- Right? No, we forget too.
- Yeah. It's like, oh, look at this.
And then he's like, I don't get it.
I was like, oh, that's right.
- I say that.
I show her TikTok.
And she's like, mm, I don't get it.
I'm like nevermind.
- Sometimes age is nothing but a number.
Okay. Sometimes.
- Age doesn't necessarily define maturity.
- Of course it needs to be legal
- Of, yeah.
- It is more about like the vibe.
And if you have things in
common, you can make it work.
- It was crazy.
'Cause there's so many
couples that you like look at
and you're like, they
don't really make sense.
But everybody up here,
like they it looked like
they all meshed really well together.
- I always thought like,
oh my gosh, six years
we're so far apart.
And then seeing couples
that were like 12 and 16
it definitely changed how I see ourselves.
- It's normal to have that reaction
knowing the big gap that we have.
But it does kind of hurt,
you know, like, wow.
You know why?
But they get it after a while.
So it's just.
(lighthearted music)